[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissin
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about at
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts are brilliant
guests this week is a fantastic comedian
Scott capira welcome to chicken AMA tree
thank you very much and the first
question we always ask people is how did
you get to where you are today you've
been a comedian for a long time yeah I
have
I am I wasn't an actor and I was doing a
play and so the people I worked with for
comedians by trade and they suggested I
give it a try so I went to a club with
them I tried in LA but I didn't really
play lived in LA - University I didn't
really like it cuz I was closeted
onstage and it didn't feel right anyway
once in San Francisco with this play I
went to a club and there's some openly
just alternative performers on stage and
I found it inspiring lots of women
performing and all sorts of double acts
and stuff and then a couple of homos it
just felt fresh comedy it felt this the
scripted quality of it felt really stale
to me when I lived in Los Angeles right
after I left
Irvine University I just felt like when
I was watching was more of a seminar or
a lecture but um I mean I was being told
things by you know middle-aged white
guys and that was the days of the open
colored shirt with sleeves pushed up
like people please everyone was copying
Jerry Seinfeld and I'm sure they were
talented I just didn't find it it didn't
touch me in any way and then starts to
go seeing these people talk openly
honestly about themselves you know at a
time when politics in San Francisco were
really charged for all sorts of reasons
you know these it
and gay rights and women's rights Allah
and it felt very relevant very real very
now and that excited me so that's why I
started doing it and then I kept acting
but then I came over here to do like a
coming-of-age play I written they had
elements to stand up in it and it won
the newcomer and then I just stayed on
and off for the next 24 years sorry I
just started getting a lot of work as a
comic I had no intention of living or
working full time as a stand-up at all
and I've been in a few films I was gonna
pursue that but um the comedy thing just
sort of took over
I liked not having to audition I liked
working when I wanted to work and
traveling what I wanted to travel and
when you're young and you start comedy
and they're tossing you from festival
the festival
it feels exciting because you're meeting
new people every couple of months and
you're going to countries you could have
never even thought of going to before
especially the work assignment because
that's exciting cuz you're meeting
people who live and work there so I
traveled before that but that kind of
traveling was more interesting to me and
you you feel as though you take part
wherever you are you're not just taking
something as a tourist you're actually
adding as a comic in South Africa or
Australia or New Zealand or Hong Kong or
all those places are so glamorous but I
probably would have never got off my
couch and planning to go there if I
hadn't been sent there for and have you
seen comedy changed since that time and
is or have you seen it regress in some
ways or adapt or you know I mean I think
I thought from what I can see in terms
because I mostly close shows so I I see
you know the ends of shows
I don't really unless I'm working clubs
out of town I've seen a lot of actually
new comics recently I've been really
inspired by the storytelling in the
narrative aspect which I thought had
been kind of lost for a while because I
play places like you know I play
mainstream clubs now a mainstream to me
but maybe they're still alternative in a
way there
working men's clubs but there's
something there's an expectation for
someone closing a show like that or even
on the bill that you have to be kind of
joke driven and it's got to be bam bam
bam bam bam you don't want to slow down
or or the temptations to perform for the
staff if you work there a lot because
the bar staff get bored and they're like
are you gonna do that grande fills our
material the audience back and then you
know you leave stage five minutes early
you gotta get paid and the guy who owns
the clubs like I can't pay you into your
time what I did he said you know you're
not working for the bar staff you're
working for me so don't take suggestions
from the next time that didn't happen to
be better happened to friend it was a
good story for me to hear but but I do
sort of admit you know I've been booking
a lot of solo shows on the road not just
to prepare for Edinboro but also because
I want the stage time because I want the
chance to open up to an audience and see
where they're at what's going on locally
and not just rush through it's a not
rush but you know it just become a bit
of a bit roped because the audience
wants jokes I mean I was the commedia
this weekend and it's a great club I
mean it's fine but the Late Show on
Saturday can be a bit circumspect it's
it's a much lesser price it usually gets
a room apparently of drunken students
yeah I was looking forward to actually
cuz I do a lot of universities in the US
and despite what I hear from other
headliners I like university campuses I
think they're exciting I think these
kids are really politically driven I
think they know a lot about what's going
on around them I think the social media
online has really engaged them they feel
a part of the world around them now when
I went to university we all felt like
we're in a bubble little but we wanted
that actually we wanted you know to
party take drugs not really be involved
in what's going on out there but now I
think young people between the ages 28
or 18 and 25 or really want to be a part
of I mean the politics going on the us
right now show that n here so anyway I
enjoy it and I looked forward to it
Saturday the shows have been great going
up to that the other comics were really
talking to me very much and I thought
I'd made people angry this happens
sometimes when I just think you know she
[ __ ] hate me because I'm in the green
room with some female comic I've never
but I'm engaging her asking her so many
questions about herself and my husband
has to this
get me to stop talking because I haven't
realized that she hasn't asked me one
question about myself yet because what
did she give a [ __ ] she's 23
I'm 55 I'm her dad's age or older and
she doesn't care anything about Who I am
or what I'm doing and I just think
comics were meant to be chatting anyway
so I'd spent a whole weekend not talking
anyone backstage and then I'm but the
shows have been going well and I went
out Late Show Saturday and I did a bunch
of news to about Thai boys and I love I
lost them in the first four minutes I
lost and talking about Thai boy stuffed
in a cave and I thought it was okay now
cuz they're fine but I said something
about you know you know you gonna
understand why the family's upset when
that happens cuz it's like losing us all
right so if anyone who misses story
young footballers yeah anyway the Thai
boys for the cake in case you were in
the cave the Thai boys so there but
Donnie's obvious he knew I was talking
about right and I said some other jokes
about Tigers anyway some guys just took
me on he still he's a he's grooming me
on Twitter right no he's stalking me on
Twitter
really yeah currently and um I don't
mind people could say you know what I
mean it's like I dealt with him but he
poisoned through or our interaction did
so so it might harsh with him so just to
clarify so war so what actually happened
you know I was closing the show there
were two comics on I walked out to close
it it was late around midnight yeah and
you expectations is it's it's 70 instead
of 250 like they usually pack them in in
the comedian yeah there are 70 people in
there and I said wow this is nice it's
intimate the preview so they packed him
in like Thai boys in the cage for which
their client is trying not to and
looking down
and their clients I'm so horny anyway so
you gotta get the little ones working
anyway they're all fine and now
everyone's eating again the point is I
said that and the crowd went a bit quiet
and there are two people from this is
what I mean there are two people from
Hong Kong in the front row and they've
been identified as being from Hong Kong
they were a couple and I started talking
about oh I've been heckled recent by
someone from China maybe you know him
now from the audience in [ __ ] [ __ ]
middle class Brighton do all those
ethnic concerns with no mine or your
friends of their own have you been to
Brighton lately yes very very white and
by the way the G from LGBT has been
removed because gay men are men so
they've taken the G out I'm just telling
you it's no longer a wild card I can
play especially with gay lesbian and
transgender audiences they're the worst
but middle-class people in Brighton have
heard the word that we're no longer
alternative so I'm playing to him full
of people think I'm like them right yeah
so they start to turn that's a no I got
no no no what I brothers I know and the
Chinese people are [ __ ] like she's a
bit grouchy girls cross but you know
they were fine yeah
they didn't need anyone to defend them
but between that and this cut with the
truth by the way after he helped me more
jokes and I you know hey I slammed him
five times in a row he passed out
so was that the force of the put-down oh
yeah whatever with a fight you were to
tap his arm they woke him up no I said I
I said I'd hope they know what chucked
you I hope you were [ __ ] dead you
can't and it was that tone of the room
that I had to now complete the show at
12:15 by then and they're really really
hammered and I thought nuts just closed
a show but closed the show because the
host had left and said can you finish
off the show and I thought well since
we're finishing let's just finish now so
I closed it in about 18 minutes um I
said I told the audience this is what
you get when you behave that way you get
this show next time go to club thinking
I might want to laugh cuz in you I said
you gonna come in a pub I date you
you're cut the comedy things up by the
way cuz you can amuse yourself but if
you then go and you're offended you
should blow off your own pumpkin at
sunrise because things are only gonna
get worse
for you tomorrow good night so just I've
[ __ ] had it
I was tired it was hot I know but you
know if you don't scream no at the comic
don't yell no it's not about your
boundaries no one knows you no one gives
a [ __ ] what offends you you're over
there
I'm over here the lights are pointed
this way I have the mic the mic step if
you don't like it do it two people
actually get up angrily scream at me
grab your jackets and walk out angrily
screaming me what what if I possibly
said that would elicit that sort of
response nothing I wish I had my fault
that wasn't rough enough on them I kind
of felt bad leaving early I should have
stayed up there and done the grunt felt
our material just [ __ ] watch them
just one by one walk out but I I just
you know at this point now I just I
don't see the point in fighting that
battle I also don't want to turn people
away from from that Club the comedian's
trying to you know is yeah probably like
every other comedy club in the country
struggling to keep people in I mean I
from what I could tell they're doing
well I think it's a great club a lot of
people do a lot of comics think it's the
best club in the country I think it's
wonderful you know you get to go to
Brighton you have a nice weekend they
put you up there really generous yeah
it's a great gig I wanted to go why I
was really thrilled cuz I got there on
Friday night done the Congress for
complaining about the crowd I thought
that we had a nine Welsh state party in
I love a good stag party I think that
are fantastic there's there's a way to
play a stag party hen parties are but
they can be touchy because of stags you
can [ __ ] with the stag you know make fun
of him and the guys love it yeah oh yeah
that's well and they'll join in that's
what they want yeah that's why they're
there with hens you can't make fun of
the bride you can't call her fat or stew
because you do that the hens all getting
up on you right yeah yeah but where's
she with this voice or really any male
harassing a woman people don't want to
see it that's sad that's fine but this
stag I was Welsh I've got a little bit
whilst material I did it all and then I
I knew his name's I kept calling back to
it yeah and they [ __ ] they loved it
yeah so oddly on Sunday when I was
leaving one of the comics on the bill I
ran into the train station he was really
nice to me and I think he just been
distracted all weekend he's great guys
really good comic actually and he took
me to breakfast and I thought
nice to me now oh it's cuz I failed last
night he said again he said he'd left
the building if I didn't say good night
but as I'm describing the Late Show he
said yeah I saw it
I'm like so you were there I think he
was waiting for me to lie about it like
most comics would yeah but I don't and
he said you know you've got nothing to
prove it's fine and I said well now you
think that and now you like me cuz I
[ __ ] up cuz the two shows before I've
done really well I close them and I
guess that seems as intimidation I don't
know I don't know why anyone responds
the way they do to anything I say to a
lot of comics on the road hey what you
guys doing this weekend oh I'm working
on material in my room well I can't see
the way I can't wait to see the way that
reflects yourself and you're set
tomorrow yeah and then I watch the set
and it's the same stick in the same
place to the same seaton and that's fine
I don't care but it's like well let's go
to a movie or have a drink or go
together or something it's Cardiff
there's nothing else to do I guess I'm a
[ __ ] I guess I don't know well I was
gonna say yeah you've demonstrated some
of them already but I was gonna say do
you think of yourself as an edgy comment
do you think you're edgy I just you know
when your ass has comedy changed it came
to mind that when I first came over and
this maybe maybe I'm remembering this
incorrectly but when I first came over
especially the a number of friends
because in those days
comics one that most of us when we lost
money our management to the hit so a lot
of comedians took a lot more chances see
some love more double acts a lot but
there were more women on the circuit
then really oh yeah I mean without women
now is good because the real cause of it
because of the what's happened the last
few years has really pushed young women
up yeah yeah but for oh there's like 10
or 12 years there were there almost no
women on the circuit and when I first
came over there were absolutely no
openly gay comics on the circuit when
was this car this was 94 95 Julie and it
was too famous to to the circuit by then
way too famous and that weird thing had
just happened on TV for him anyway he
wouldn't going back on the circuit there
is nobody else I'm not saying there
weren't gay people I mean openly once
yeah there's no one talking about it on
stage which was a benefit to me I don't
understand why some comics complain
about their gender now or their
ethnicity as being a problem it never is
it sets you apart it's always a good
thing to be different at least it was
there were a lot of different people in
I mean a lot of larger clubs needed to
sell sell sell because the competition
kicked up in the late 90s early 2000s
and so the show has became less of a
rocking boat is the only way I can
describe it it became less I wouldn't
say it became more consistent in the
performance you saw there was there
wasn't I wouldn't I wouldn't say the
chances were being taken because
comedies always a risk it's not an easy
way to make a living for anybody but I
think what I did see was a lot more of a
steady sale and every show I was
performing and and the expectations on
at least I think on me at least my
management told me this was that I be as
consistent as possible and to me I had I
felt as though I had to hit a hit every
time now my husband works in the comedy
club so I know from him from his
experiences with the owner who stands
behind the bar within one watch there's
a lot of comedy it doesn't matter who
you are if that club owner does not hear
laugh consistently every 15 seconds
you're not gonna get invited back do you
think people have become more sensitive
that might have happened because of
social media and constant influx and no
but that's not necessarily a bad thing
but do you think it has changed maybe
but you can you can prick it their
sensibilities a bit more I think also
comics have gotten older and their
financial responsibilities have become
greater they have kids now they've got
mortgages and they're less I think
willing to take risks on comedy stages
and maybe they never did maybe they
never that was never part of who they
were but certainly they're not gonna do
it now and I think young people choose
comedy now as a as a like the way people
choose law or medicine used like I
described you used to fall into it you
never thought you'd be you never chose
it it just sort of happened to you for a
lot of people people have done boats or
on the beach or slept unconscious they
didn't really you know but now young
people choose it and I think the
explosion on TV and whatever they think
they they see their myopic about the
career path they want something specific
and certain they want to be on bbc1 a
Saturday nights or they want to have a
panel show or they want to be a compair
and and to do that when they they're
management because certain management
companies kind of encompass them they
they you know take them to their shows
and they watch them closely and they
shape them they formed them and that
seems to me to be sort of a different
strategy than what I was accustomed to
when I first
so yeah I think all of us changed but
the reason I'm asking you about whether
people have become more sensitive is you
clearly went into that gig that you've
been talking about right with an
expectation the Thai boy material
whatever would be acceptable by that
point is of what I'm getting there
would have been a point in some way in
your career where you would have gone to
a gig you would have done that material
right you would have felt absolutely
safe and I thought I was safe in
Brighton as a gay man doing something
alternative at midnight I couldn't
imagine that the people right you're
right I did
but you know I have a lack of a stop but
I had off switch I could have gone on
stage and done the Sun I'd done in the
previous show which would have worked
perfectly well but I thought I want to
do something fresh a bit different I
wanted some I wanted you some of my
Edinburgh Fringe material I wanted to do
stuff about gun control I did tell a gun
control joke that got absolutely no
response what was a joke well it's more
assuming I'm a I'm American but don't
worry I'm not a [ __ ] I mean you know I
own a gun but that's because I believe
in gun control and I want to win the
[ __ ] argument for a change it's a
joke about what I do with my gun I don't
really fire it anyway so and they just
[ __ ] stared at me now it might have
been just because it was late and they
enjoyed the job but I was i I think the
whole thing I could have had them had
that interchange with that unhappy
person those people storming out and
then the Chinese had that not all
happened but you know 18 minutes in you
had I had soured that room and I'm not
gonna blame I've never ever blamed an
audience and I'm not gonna [ __ ] start
now my job is to make my material
accessible to roomful of strangers it's
not babysitting so much as opening up
their minds about the way gay men behave
changing their minds because we're not
just all there to decorate Brighton some
of us are there for other reasons so I
want them to see that and to enjoy it
and they had up till that moment and I
think you know I think when you actually
think changed I think you're asking me
have audiences sensitive
yeah become more tender and about
certain things they have I think one
good thing is I'm less likely to get you
know tattooed forearms crossed in
Birmingham of the Glee when I walk out
in Sam queer cuz that used to happen 10
or 15 years ago but that doesn't happen
now
yeah oh they don't give a [ __ ]
especially young people young people
assume that gay men and women have
always been able to get married I've
always been able to join the military
those things are not issues to them so
you can you can you know cooperate with
you on those subjects and you have to
find a different way to make them funny
if you want to I think the challenge has
always been there to if if your comic
like me to find out what people's
sensitivities are and elicit laughter
from those and try to illuminate their
own hypocrisy I mean like I say people
fragile about ethnic minorities and you
can I can bet that most of that room in
Brighton doesn't the clothes black
friend now whether that's true or not
it's funny for me to point that out and
point out what that could actually mean
I mean you know I only read the Guardian
for the typos but I understand reading
it that you know people they want to be
engaged and involved in current
political situations so I don't see how
I can stand on the stage in front of
strangers for 25 minutes and not give
them the chance to engage when I think
about the political issues belittle
cause issue in Marina and at that you
know you know when it's funny I did a
show in in in North London recently and
there was an American couple in front
row from this from the South but they
were posh Americans they spoke well and
they owned guns and they voted for Trump
and as I and they were not shy about
telling us those things although they
knew at first did not tell me they knew
enough they'd been here long enough as
tourists but then they decided to tell
me and and that was a room full of
left-leaning Jews and these two people
and they're about my age and they were
white and I know how to talk to these
people the room that the British got
tenser and [ __ ] tenser because what I
was doing was making fun of them to
their face but
they weren't getting it I was performing
to them for the rest of the room and I
was complimenting them I was I was I was
flirting with them to make them think
not that I agree with them but what they
were saying was okay
and the rest of the room was completely
horrified with what they were saying
right but it was making them tenser and
tenser and I couldn't tell what they
were angry about but if you're not on
the edge of your seat in a comedy show I
don't know why the [ __ ] you're there are
you there to have a mirror held up to
you to show you how great you are
because that's why I don't perform in
gay and lesbian clubs because that's
what they want and I'd rather chew on
ground glass and perform a [ __ ] Cup
in South London and wave my fist around
say how great gay people are I don't
give a [ __ ] about that if you want that
then hire a [ __ ] [ __ ] or a [ __ ]
diva or a drag queen hi are those people
cuz that's what they'll do for you but
that's not what I do if you want that
get a juggler go to children's party but
this you're in a comedy club in 2018 and
my precedent has just tried to have a
coup in your country he's just tried to
dismantle your governmental structure in
three days and he almost did it
that's how weak your political system is
right now does any of this mean anything
to you
so why I'm talking to them about Trump
you know I'm talking about your Prime
Minister and the political situation
here and stuff and they were laughing
about casual all is oh yeah people
should hear [ __ ] my god they shot bleep
it on the Tuesday with a gold mine when
shams for them you know I try to take
advantage of that but don't you think
that there is I've seen it more and more
and I get quite a lot to to younger
people and I see it and now that I'm 36
I see it in people in their mid 20s or
early twenties certain words they tense
up and the shutters calm down I used to
do this bit about my mum supporting
Trump and how she's a disabled Latin
American woman and I'm just like you
know you like him but you don't [ __ ]
like you and then and then and then a
bit about her right and left used to
come to getting you to come together
that bit used to kill I can't do that
bit anymore the moment I say the word
Trump everybody holds Bank well he's a
bit of a downer he is I just said it's
hard with him because you know he's on
the front page of every
newspaper he's the most famous person in
the world I think people are afraid he's
gonna win in 2020 really well yeah and I
think people just they're just they're
sick of it
it might be I've been that response well
but I don't you mean about young people
they do claim although I think it's all
hype to have trigger words and they can
claim that you know they want safe space
and all that but if in the first few
minutes of your act like one technique I
try to master although I'm not gonna yet
I'm trying to get a friend of a is to
dispel all that the first five minutes
so that we can kind of move on if you
can let them now that what a safe space
actually is and what feminism actually
is because there because some of them
are too stupid to know what it means and
and they think they know what is trigger
word is but they don't so if you can
tell them what democracy actually is and
what it would look like if they were
actually practicing it and how miserable
they be then if you can get that all out
of the way then they might cooperate I'm
worried about Edinboro I have to be
honest with you I am why
because I'm [ __ ] dreading it already
because I mean I love the fringe it's
kind of it shaped me as a comic in the
first few years I was here and I'm not
it's uh for the reason some people are
about the expense of all that we take
off that's all our decisions but I'm
doing this thing with Bob Slayer where
you know people pay seven pounds online
are there extra seats I go up to the bar
upstairs and say there are empty seats
if anyone's coming down watch the show
and they pass it back into the end but I
don't know that I want I don't know that
I want but just people that don't know
what I do in that room I don't want to
spend a half hour on them working out
their [ __ ] says [ __ ] off with your
sensitivities and your sensibility and
your drunken I'm on a nine twenty your
laddish behavior it's not fair the
people who've paid actually even if
they're only ten or twelve they've
actually paid and they want to see what
I have to say I don't want to deal with
those [ __ ] bald [ __ ] in the back who
couldn't wait to get away from their
wives or or five women in a pack whose
I've been shopping away on or sunburn a
two-tire to listen or whatever or twenty
five-year-old who thinks they know
anything I just I don't I don't we want
the show
isn't about you ever since 9/11 they all
think sarafina's are of equal importance
but they're incorrect unless they're on
stage you want to write a check for
three grand get this room that [ __ ]
dude next year but for now shut your
[ __ ] but no one tells people no anymore
that's a problem to me
no one system you might be wrong have
you actually asked yourself the question
do I know anything because really it's
about the questions and not your [ __ ]
answers cuz nobody really gives a [ __ ]
about your personal experience I mean my
problem with Twitter is not the comics
go on in her house it's that they don't
do it in a funny way because your job is
to write jokes about it not to tell me
about in the second half of your show
how you've been raped
how is that my problem why isn't this
funny why should I feel uncomfortable in
your presence why have you kidnapped me
lock the door and put me in this room to
listen to your griping it's like this is
not why am i pretending to enjoy this
why why why
I just think if there's a narrative
attached stuff that makes it interesting
then that's great and honestly my first
Edinburgh show where I want all those
all that [ __ ] it wasn't necessarily that
funny I mean you know I think I had the
the narrative that thing were you admit
things to an audience were you kidnapped
them I knew that's what I was doing when
I was 30 years old I knew that those
people couldn't leave the room because I
was the first queer that ever sat in a
room with ELISA tell a few jokes but
really that that that whole show is
about my first sexual experience with my
cousin in in a in a in a trailer in
California this summer Elvis had died
that was what that show is about and it
wasn't funny and that wasn't funny at
all and they [ __ ] his day because they
felt an obligation to I knew that I knew
I had them hogtied I knew I did and I've
done that now and what I'd like to do
now is amused and entertain an audience
for 55 minutes because to me that's more
of a challenge but whenever you do you
know don't assume when you go to a show
that that comic is actually there to
make you feel better about about who you
are so you sang essentially the
audience's have become more entitled
well listen I really admire people that
make the sacrifice to go to live
performance because I often times
I can't [ __ ] be bothered to you know
but um but uh you know what I say to
people if they want if they ask me when
they see a flower show you see your show
to me it's like what my yoga teacher
tells me was just just come with an open
mind and an open heart that's all you
got to do if you have any preconceived
notions about how things should be or
what a performance is leave them outside
and it believed me I spent a lot of the
show every five or seven minutes
reminding them that so I give them a lot
of red flags and if by the end they feel
in some way she did or I don't know
harassed that I kind of think that sort
of problem I think if someone feels if
in an audience someone feels offended
just usually their problem I don't know
them I can't like that's what I was
asking about her sensitivity because I'm
from Russia and I tell the story
sometimes on stage about someone saying
to me go back to Russia you [ __ ]
right and the Asian that's quite a bit
that's quite a lot of boxes and it's
always the Asian people to laugh the
most and it's always the white people
that look around to make sure it's safe
and and I always wonder what that's
about I do you know I know you mean I I
tell the Amish my husband's black in the
first few minutes of the show I used to
I don't know and par the reason so I can
drop the n-bomb about five times during
the stuff and um think of yourself as an
edgy comedian well what is edgy really I
mean you know my husband gets asked what
you say as accents for Brazil what's
your what's your what's your what's your
background and in Britain people mean
you know what are you and in results of
offensive questions so he just tells
people now I'm black and that shuts them
the [ __ ] up they don't ask any more
questions because people do in this
country are afraid of black people I'm
from the US I'm not afraid of black
people I live I live in an integrated
city when I was younger
you think people are afraid like be
terrified and I think that no one knows
how white people don't talk to black
people this country at OU all
people know how to do is impersonate
them if they can and it's a pathetic
attempt we think all that stuff that
young people try to do I can't even I
can't even okay but you know the lingo
the colloquialism well you're like
environmental that yes yeah and these
days it's the richer and whiter there
are the words I try to deal away and
they think it's groovy and cool to be
black which is so offensive it's so
offensive that if I say my husband's
black the unnies allows me to talk about
blacks you think I'm doing it so that
two-thirds the way through the show I'm
like you know he's not black I just say
that I mean and they can't embrace the
idea that is that they you know at some
clubs in this country the compare you'll
be in a room full of 300 people there'll
be a mixed-race couple the front row
he'll he or she will talk to the white
person know why person no I could skip
the black person I've seen it happen so
many times so the first thing I do on
stage is say how you doing the black guy
cuz he's probably offended that no one's
talking to him and wonders why you know
so anyway so you think people in Britain
are scared of black people white people
in Britain
yeah that's incredible I know well
they're criminalized in every way but I
thought it's an America where race
relations were worse that's what I
believe the hype that's what I was told
you're from Russia you know better you
know the way they talk about people are
from Moscow in this country like you're
all [ __ ] criminals and drug dealers
yeah
that's what you can afford live here
yeah no of course
black people are represented must and I
think in a much more healthy way in the
u.s. I mean and of course their problems
but I I we had a black president anyway
so um you know whenever when black
people are seen in positions of power in
this country as as randomly as it
happens through they're treated like
like they're lucky or they're ignored or
they're belittled like the female MP
who's made some mistakes but she's
treated like she's like like like it's
her fault the labor part of your [ __ ]
up no Diana Baur yeah like his balls in
her lap because she had a I guess a
diabetic overthrow on the radio a couple
of times
her mind for figures I what her excuse
but you know she made a couple of
mistakes Jesus not Faraj anyway so yeah
you know anyway so yes there so when
you're when you're playing a comedy club
in New York or CNN or LA or Chicago if
you're on stage you better talk to the
ethnic people in the room you better be
able to tell the difference for you
Nicaraguan accent and a Honduran accent
and a know and a Mandarin Chinese
somebody speaks Mandarin Chinese I
suppose someone from my car you've got
to do the access correctly and you've
got to refer to them or else to come up
to you to the show say why don't you
talk about ma'am offend you left me out
really yeah it's a difference that
really happened of course it's happened
to me in New York
it's amazing cuz in the UK my suddenly
my experience would be that if you did
an accent you would instantly be treated
it but not if it's the accent of the not
the ethnic people your your your sadder
I think they like it that they do right
corner white people don't of course they
would you know they gotta line up I
don't know what to tell them I don't
know what to say except you know pull
the [ __ ] cucumber out here button
live a little
[Music]
you mentioned politics you don't do
political materials so much in your said
at least from water I do
depending on the show there's a
political improv show of the store that
we do this really politically motivated
some of that material leaks into my set
yes so what do you make of what's
happening in in politics right now well
I feel like the world is turning right
and I think that's what that's the
conflict audiences have when you bring
up Trump because audiences in comedy
clubs in central London at least or most
of London tend to be left-leaning when I
did a free speech comedy show comedy
Unleashed
that's about how did you do it we've had
him on the show yeah that's right yeah
and he might have mentioned that about
half the audience in the first night
we're right-wing people and they showed
up thinking that in them free speech in
a comedy show meant right wing calm
because ice age finally talking what
they can talk about because comedy is so
left-leaning in Jan um so I feel like if
you talk about politics any comedy show
in London or Edinburgh or Birmingham or
you know in urban areas it might be a
good idea to gauge where the audience is
at but I had to I mean between the three
of us on these three cameras and that
hot guy sitting all of us again I don't
and I mean this in every respectful way
I don't give a [ __ ] what their politics
are I don't care they're not my friends
the show is about me you just need and
if they want to disagree or get upset
well good for them it's hard to react to
anything now cuz everything's on an iPad
now in kiss so if you're in the room
with me and you want to share your
thoughts that's fine your feelings not
so partial about their transient right
and I'm not dealing with your feelings
again I don't know you this isn't a
therapy session we're not gonna break up
in as well
discussion groups to talk about your
abandonment low self-esteem and your ego
problems I don't give a [ __ ] but if you
disagree with something I'm saying on
stage while I'm saying it not five
minutes later and you want to talk I'd
suggest you raise your hand but
you wash yell somebody nothing let's get
into it that's why riding a show takes
so long for me because I risk every
political idea I expressed our research
I've gotta have a backup for it I have
made a mistake in the past of saying
things flippantly on stage I didn't have
a backup for and it's always those
moments when you get caught by an
audience member smarter than you and you
you know
you've gotta have a joke about it I mean
I think I think that you asked about the
political situation I think the only
place that we can deal with it now is on
a comedy stage because it's the only
place that people gonna allow someone
the the the breath or the girth to bring
up these wide subjects and sort of
lighten them a bit pull the plug on them
let some of the air out
open a window so it smells so stuffy in
here and actually discuss people's
hypocrisy in a way that's that's
light-hearted that's the thing is people
ask me you know I've done a few
interviews for the fringe and they're
like you know who do you hunt down
offensive material and this offensive
economy I don't ever look for what I
think is offensive
I look up things I find her funny you
know like the cave boys or whatever you
know I find that [ __ ] hilarious so if I
find dozens funny and if I find fun
shooting teenagers in some way funny cuz
I mean have you talked to an adolescent
suffice if I find some of that you know
they're not Dennis my job you know to
find out what and if people oh how can
you make fun of a high school shooting
I'm like how can't you what other option
frankly is there though I know this
sounds grand and very kumbaya but let
other option is there to survive any of
this other than to laugh at it because
really the amount of control any of us
have of our destiny is so clearly not in
our hands I think that's what upsets
people is they realize the British
Petroleum of the world not us so just
obviously they clearly matter who you
vote for because Teresa made that vote
of the last summer didn't affect any of
the outcome Theresa May is doing exactly
what she wants to do I suspect that she
brought Trump over knowing what he'd say
so the people turned against brexit even
more the more he supports it the less
the British public like it
whatever her journey is with brexit she
may be playing
of us no voters might as well take their
votes their ballots and flush them down
the toilet for all the difference
they've made over the last five years in
the country and in the US as well I mean
when brexit happened I knew Trump would
win I know that those elections are
fixed I know they are and the
gerrymandering by the Senators fixes
them anyway so it doesn't matter how you
vote in California they don't even come
to California the presidential nominees
to do campaigns anymore because they
know that California the largest state
in the union with one tenth of
population of the u.s. it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter and what do you think
a trump and especially I would like to
explore as a comedian because as a
comedian watching political comics and
inverted commas talk about Trump's he's
orange he's a dick he's got small hands
I'm like really this is the best that
you can do is a professional comedian I
love your comedic talents I mean I
thought about voting for him because
he's against gay marriage no I know I
talk about yeah cuz I hear people saying
he's like the most Pro gay president
America's ever had well it's bouncing I
imagine you find that he's he's he's
ceding the Supreme Court with judges who
don't feel that way so it may fall into
their into their manicured hands whether
or not okay so able to get married in a
couple years so whatever he says you
have to follow Trump's actions not what
he says cuz you know he's just a lot of
[ __ ] right from one day to the next
so I look at what he does
and it's really about the judicial
appointments in the u.s. more than
anything that's the most frightening but
um you know I think he's just an a comic
and I think he's a performer I think is
a populist I think he's about what
comics do is he disrupts people and he
creates chaos anyone's complete control
and I think that he doesn't feel any
loyalty and he said his ambitions are
limitless
and I think that he's immediate he's a
he's a media and corporate mogul from
New York he's a property developer from
Manhattan so he's a gangster so he has
no loyalty to anyone including his
children anyone you've seen him to
almost turn his kids out a couple of
times so and
sena laws for the thickest thickest
possibly shed i have ever seen
put it on a camera and he likes that
because that's that's his that's his
that's a spokesmodel internationally he
sends that kid everywhere so he doesn't
have to go and i think he's he's he's a
bit of a genius really well don't you
think that he's manipulating the world
right now i mean if he's not smart how
[ __ ] thicker we he came over here and
almost completely disrupted the entire
political structure of this country
within a matter of hours i that
interview give the day later mail and
then he got home and said Oh Putin
saying I am that wouldn't not would and
he has ninety percent approval ratings
in the Republican Party that's the
highest of almost any president in the
history of the u.s. ninety percent
he's doing something right I don't know
I for me to say that he's stupid seems
weird because how I don't is he or is he
just a G yes have manipulating the media
and he knew that like he said if you ran
for a mocha Republican they believe
anything it says the party's just stupid
he's got them in the grip of his tiny
hands I don't know but you're right I
wouldn't what I wouldn't do is is is
talk about how how stupid orange he is
because that's not the point
that's not the issue these are what I'd
rather not to is is dismantle his
character it's really his policies I try
to go after because you said that what
he was doing in America was terrifying
would you just expand upon he's trying
to just ride - he wants to expel people
who who aren't white he wants to cleanse
the us when he said you know that um
what does it clean the pond
what is it sure is wrong you know that
where he got that quote from no that's
Mussolini so when he when he borrowed
that quote from Mussolini
he was speaking to not white people in
California he was speaking to the same
people that elected Reagan when Reagan
said when he was elected when he was
nominated for the
for the office the first time by spotty
he was in in Alabama and he said I'm
putting my own Mississippi I'm putting
my I'm putting my feet in the
Mississippi mud letting you know I'm
with you and took his shoes off and put
his feet in the mud and what that meant
to southerners was he hates black people
it's it's a it's a coded term that meant
a lot to a part of his party that he
wanted to be loyal to him
I mean Reagan was famously a race baiter
and I think Trump is too but hold on
drain the swamp is about Washington it's
not about the country sure sure it is if
you are a neo-fascist living in the US
or you're right of Mussolini in the
Republican Party you know exactly what
he means you know that when gore Vidal
call DC a swamp in two of his books
people accused him of being racist
because he he mentioned the swamps of
Africa Trump is preying on people's
minds he's he's creating imagery in
their minds that means something to them
that it doesn't mean to you because
you're not from there but in America if
you're from Arkansas the swamp means
black people running with changing on
their ankles away from prison with dogs
chasing them it brings up imagery in
their minds of all sorts of things that
you don't that don't make sense to you
so and again it's a misleading quote so
anyway I think whether Trump is racist
and he has proven business-wise that he
is he is at least uncomfortable doing
misses with black people because he
wouldn't rent to them when he was
working for his dad so and that I think
that he's a horrible racist that's what
makes me nervous about him how you can
live a Manhattan to be racist although
frankly when you're gonna Manhattan now
they've pushed there's almost no ethnic
community left in the island you know
even though Harlem has been cleansed to
black to the black committee like a
terrace disco so I think he's trying to
urbanize and and Clorox the entire
country he wants people to live at his
living standards but when you have a
capitalistic society like that you can
have a lot of losers but Trump doesn't
care about the losers there's no safety
now in the US or its diminishing and
that's what freaks me out because I grew
up with a single mom we lived out of a
car for a while we grow out you know my
dad left
mom she didn't have a high school
diploma she had to find a job in a way
to support three kids and it was very
very difficult I was younger so I know
what it's like to grow up without a
safety net and I know how terrifying it
is and my mom couldn't rent they didn't
rent to single women in San Francisco in
those days we had to move far away that
the commute it was horrible for her and
I think it's kind of what killed her
young frankly and I think and she had a
bit more support my momma might a little
longer but you know there isn't that not
the kind you have here and do you think
we're going the same way in this country
I think with brexit maybe some of the
people that felt vulnerable the voter
for bricks that are gonna be the hardest
hit I think we know that now and I think
when you you know I think that I think
that the the health of any country
however powerful they think they are is
not the way they deal with the wealthy
is the way you deal with it's a
disenfranchised in that country whoever
they are and that's people with drug
addictions or single moms or people that
don't identify themselves through
identity politics but identify
themselves in other ways if you speak to
someone like your mother who's having a
very difficult time either way you
described her she might be I don't know
the way you described her
and you asked that personnel that
identify themselves I think the last
thing on her mind is whether or not
she's a Tory or or in the labour party
yeah I think she thinks
well I'm these things I'm a working mom
or I have these kids or I can't find a
job because of these ailments I have she
identifies herself by her circumstances
not her [ __ ] politics but when I'm in
front of a roomful of white middle class
people are telling me what their
political identity is and how I should
match that that's when I get angry
because I think you don't know my
[ __ ] story and you're here to listen
to it and if you aren't then you should
probably [ __ ] the [ __ ] off so I'm
worried but that's what I'm concerned
with that Trump and brexit are making
people build fortresses around
themselves and either you're allowed in
or you're not and you're either on our
side of your against it that famous
trumped a bush quote that he said when
he bombed the Middle East in in you know
the early two-thousands in response to
the bombings in New York he told Europe
year though I'm sorry or not and that
was real threat and I think that people
now
feel that way I think there's less
discourse frankly I think it you know a
conservative audience politically can be
funded or perform in front of when I've
done conferences you the greens were
good because they know how ridiculous
they are when I do a Labour Party
conference performance it's really I
gotta tell you the worst gig you can
ever say yes to is the haze the haze
thing that ahay asks that [ __ ]
Guardian sponsors name I did it I owe
like 300 people in bleacher seating
[ __ ] staring at me I'm not kidding
you
I have never I was chasing them around
the stage trying to find what their what
they what they would joke about what
what would that what what their common
weather what they found comfortable
nothing I found nothing I found nothing
it was and then I come back and some of
the guys from Comedy Store said you did
that gig I seen effort that's the worst
one 20 I said well I wanted to go to
that era I thought they'd be pretty and
I read The Guardian them think no it's
impossible you can't and um do you think
those people would just sanctimonious
and too serious and they care too much
about is that what it is all be because
there is a section of the left isn't
there that's gone a little bit in [ __ ]
right now if he's a little bit yeah I
was trying to put it gently
there's no discourse yeah there's no if
I say to them if I say um you might you
might I'd be God I got into the store
when we're talking about some of this
you you tweet stuff and I said you know
some of the allegations are obviously
incorrect and with someone who has three
children told me isn't one enough is it
one enough
and I said you mean one enough to
destroy all the careers it's destroying
one enough to now the BBC has to pay
that guy 600 thousand because they threw
a flew a helicopter over his house and
they were wrong I say I think it's
insulting to people actually been abused
or harassed that that's your stance if
you're saying that it's all the same and
if you ask a victim it's not the same
they want to hear their story have their
story heard
I've talked him off the ledge for like
seven minutes because we were doing a
show together and I know I don't think I
go on I think he still thinks I'm a con
I think he thinks I'm a kiddie diddling
[ __ ] [ __ ] that I don't I just don't
get I don't get it I don't know I don't
know where's to to to Tories can friends
mine came in Selma Edinburgh preview
last Thursday they went for drinks after
what you think I did an hour in ten
minutes just mad I ran around them and
some people know you know he's fine
they're like three kids from Sri Lanka
thank God from Sri Lankan the fourth row
they were glorious there are Muslims
young Muslim kids and they they well
there are four but one of them was
living in London a student here I'm like
what are you guys doing here my previous
we want to see comedy show and they were
just they were girl great but some of
the you know other people white
Londoners were not I got a lot of tics
like yeah and I asked the kid was he a
virgin and they the white people and I
said and he said no I [ __ ] somebody I
said did you and he said not my
girlfriend I cheated on her ten minutes
later we're talking about well I didn't
really [ __ ] her i fingered her you know
I couldn't really stick it in I'm not
ready for that but uh oh I just oh and
I'm on stage singing you know gold dust
you know yeah make it all
but you know but my Tory friends you
know and there Arthur stamps on breaks
it's hilarious because they're from a
very wealthy part of Britain the
Chiltern line I'll just say that yeah
dad their line you know why they like
their railroad better because it's from
my Chairman's which they prefer that's
actually told me which I thought was
hilarious so they I'm you know they
didn't take any of it personally
none of this there's a lot of evidence
actually the Conservatives are better
able to understand other points of view
that's why they're in power right now no
I mean that guy you ever any that party
that [ __ ] idiot how he's not taking
advantage of all of this yet you
notified Corbin well I don't support
Hamas so no he does I don't support
Hamas
I support the existence of Israel and I
support Palestine yeah but I don't
support it was as a political body
ruling Palestine I think it's probably a
bad idea
yeah I'm no I don't support the
government is Israel either but if you
go to Tel Aviv it's a lovely place and
you feel very safe hmm as a gay man you
know I don't feel harassed in any way
[Music]
do you think you can get away with more
on stage because you're gay because you
like that that's why I brought the Jia
LGBT IQ I think my Gees been removed I
really mean I took about the show I
don't think I can anymore
cuz I saw you do a bit at comedy
Unleashed this free speech coming by me
too yeah right I don't see a straight
man I'm aware of that
oh it's actually me three with my three
finger right I'll betray knees whole um
so yes but these were raped I thought it
was a guy and that's the true story by
the way it seemed to me that you were
also you were making fun of Quinn
Paltrow and it is a very good bit and I
[ __ ] stripe right why twineth yeah why
is it like a flower arranger who I had
to go dry well and it's very funny but I
don't you read her but I don't think you
read her let me finish just a question I
don't think a straight man could get
away with doing that bit on stage really
it was mine my man you might be right do
you think I'm wrong I'm I I'm wondering
if I seen anyone do it um I haven't I
hope I do I think the only way to show
respect to that surgeon and I know that
I agree with women men can be incredibly
harassed absolutely and we do live in a
rape culture if you think we don't
you're out of your mind
also again Greg Moore the single mother
you know my mom worked in a law firm at
the front desk she wasn't a lawyer's
secretary she wasn't illegal security
didn't have the education but she's the
person and all each lawyer had their own
secretary they're eight of them and they
don't she said I can't think of one
secretary not [ __ ] her lawyer her
boss right now my mom tell me that was
like that's like 12 I mean ah I know
that it's terrible that's why I try to
make fun of it it can't just be
something that people ignore in the
press or in the media can't just be
something it can't be in the media and
they're not dealt with you know my
backup story is if people come after me
I may be like you know again you don't
know when I was came at a university in
LA I was working for Dick Clark who was
a TV producer
and we used to produce New Year's rockin
Eve in October and I was a PA the
weakest the lowest of the low on the set
and I had I had men try to push me
behind bushes I had a guy jump on me in
a car I got I got out from under him
because I'm 6 foot 2 but it was
difficult so I I understand the abuse
and harassment women women and gay men
share a lot of things in common that's
what I try to draw in that also what
happened that night was the Telegraph
critic was there she said I want to see
some me two jokes she told that to
Andrew and she said I better see some me
to stuff so I told some me two jokes and
she reviewed me badly and said my act
was mean but no yes I just yeah and I
just written those me - chokes actually
really was looking forward to doing them
and then I wanted to do that story
specifically said that at the bar I'm I
better see some me two jokes no so she
saw some and then she ignore them but
the thing is I was glad because I had a
chance to try them in front of an
audience willing to hear them I don't
know that I for one that I'm telling you
I wouldn't do that me to stuff I don't
think that I'm there are some clubs I
wouldn't do it him definitely not to it
in uh-huh and I was I was a coward about
some of my stuff on Saturday at the
commedia maybe I should have gone all
the way maybe I should have done five
minutes on winneth Paltrow I do it Nana
burro I'll probably get torn to shreds
for it I probably have people walk out
and people won't come and my husband we
will have that conversation my asthma
says can you but I can't and I'm I think
you know there's no point us living in
the world and not talking about
I can't believe have to say that but I
think that to ask a question a straight
guy if he were to there's a way to do it
probably I'm trying to think of a comic
someone I think someone like who could
really although trivializing it could be
a problem too but someone who could
lighten the load of it somehow I can
think of two or three people that might
although they probably never would
because they don't need to that's the
thing I feel the need to do it it's a
vocation for me I can't ignore it I feel
I have to do it
I feel I feel dirty after if I don't do
it I feel like I've given in like I've
like I've like I've let down the team I
do which team the comedy team I think
our job is is to push them is to push it
be [ __ ]
I mean we're clowns we're knowing where
they annoying guy in the office or in
the Shakespeare play where the were that
where that guy or girl so our job is to
eat here's the thing playing all these
clubs on the road this summer I I
realized a lot of comics won't be liked
they want the others to like them like
that's strange
why forthing you'll get nothing out of
them like you'll never see them again
but what's there to like you're strange
I think it's creepy he's needy to me
when the comics are say you know when
you and on these cuz oh yeah that's not
good I get embarrassed I get like my I
don't want you to pretend like you know
me I just I want to see your story
what's your take on it and I don't I
don't necessarily want them to like the
show and play along with what I'm
talking about but that's being friends I
kind enough friends the thought of you
people like him here even talking to you
after the show he sauces me I don't mind
do the VIP shot where you do the photos
and stuff but please don't clap at me on
Twitter 18 times in a row or like this
guy stalking me from the commedia the
show's over lights are out you know the
price of admission got you the set
that's it it can imagine we be liked by
those people
it sounds exhausting to me are you not
liked enough in your life is is you know
but I mean is your biggest ambition to
be on TV
I just think cut your wrists I mean TV
is great it sells tickets
good for you I'm not saying it's a bad
thing but I'm saying if you want to be
liked or nice so that people hire you to
be on TV I just think there's you've got
a missing cog up there somewhere where
you forgotten along the way some somehow
that aren't that there's that that
there's an art to what we're doing and
it's important what we do and it's it's
not about poo jokes or your mom it's
about it's about it's about
again do you have an onion in your hand
you strip back layer after layer until
these they see that the Nexus the
nucleus of something I don't know how
people memorize their material I can't
hear what they're saying half the time
I just know I mean you know the other
night that's commedia there's a comma
concise you know I didn't mean you but I
just boom and the security guy next
meets are you okay now yeah I didn't
mean to let that noise out but it's just
what I was feeling was I just kids
[ __ ] it on with it I just how do i do
just sit through it I I don't know I you
know it's why don't go to place cuz ten
minutes in you know what the place about
yeah the days yeah a new play so it's
like oh I see where we're going here he
said that I want to be changed I want to
be alerted someone gonna know before or
else I get a lot of [ __ ] to do like a
boxes to tick I can I got dry cleaning I
get stuff so I want to bring something
to the table
but I want everyone to have a chair at
the table that's what liberalism is we
all give someone a seat whether we agree
with them or not and then we listen and
we shut our [ __ ] mouths for a minute
if we're sitting in the audience and we
listen I think that's the most
reactionary but also liberal thing you
can do is to listen to someone you don't
agree with and let them explain to you
what their point of view is otherwise we
might as well just all wrap ourselves in
Tupperware and be Royals and have no
experience with the real world if you
want to be those I feel so bad for those
kids and those women who have married
them if you want to live that life
because that's what that life is you
want to turn yourself off from every
human experience then you do that but
that's I think a psychosis all right
that's a great way to win the world I
mean the slit your wrists line you just
seem appropriate but that's also good
that's how your mind works yeah actually
I'm sorry is like know so what you want
to do the the famous final question
Constantine what yes I do the question
that we always ask people at the end is
is there something that we ought to be
talking about that we're not talking
about we being society not just me and
Francis oh right well if you'd asked me
a few weeks ago I would said kids in a
cage in the US because they were there
occasionally oh all right so I thought
you said cave and that's where I thought
you were coming back to that no but
there's so much stuff about trumpet and
they were ignoring these people talked
about that quite a bit done yeah
eventually but you know they respond we
can have four no it's all right I was
like white and um and then all those
signaling are four years actually but uh
I think now it's probably it's probably
the the removal that the dismantling of
people's personal rights that the
political system is your civil rights
are being a minute which ones
well in the u.s. it would it's things
like abortion and your right to free
speech because Trump is trying to
dismantle the free media but I think
that's also I think those two things are
gonna be a problem here soon to I worry
about your course in your judicial
system
I mean I think yeah I think people have
become accustomed to living on bread
crumbs
I think austerity has made people I
think you should worry about the NHS
I think the NHS is Britain's greatest
power
that's silly war and all its rural [ __ ]
is [ __ ] I think I think you should
be thanking Adolf Hitler
really I said criticizing him of it yes
one Geographic Channel
because there that Hitler you would have
an NHS and that's the best thing
Britain's ever produced I think I worry
about that but it doesn't seem anyone's
I mean people say they are but are they
worried about it let you go get worried
about it you if unless you lived in the
country with no health care you don't
know what is fine yeah yes tariffs it's
absolutely terrible to watch your mother
die with a stack of bills on her desk
and not be able to do anything about it
so yeah my mother always said she was a
[ __ ] right well if you haven't been
utterly depressed by this after I do
subscribe comedies great though I really
think that this is you know you could
talk about these things in a comedy
right yes it's only plays yeah well you
know what that cutting into our final
bit but actually that's why I got into
comedy
I remember watching people like George
Carlin and Bill Hicks really talk about
stuff mm-hmm and then I started doing
comedy like three years ago whatever was
and I started go into comedy clubs and I
very quickly realized that's not what
comedy is anymore but it really and I
try to get a little bit of that but I
just find that like you said the
audience doesn't gradually been trained
to here's the tree here's a tree here's
a tree this is the tree you know a -
suggest if you tour tour with an
alternative comic because it will - in
the audience's ear so that by the time
you come out on stage they'll be much
more open just every second matter
that's a trick I learned early on here
because this isn't new
this limited expanse on audience how you
it's your job to you to you know pry
them open a bit and there's tricks you
can use and one is you know
I have a black female comic open for you
I mean they're loads of good ones get a
good you get a good you know get a great
female and if she's black that's great
because in the audience will be like
wait a woman when I had a woman open for
me they would announce her name over the
PA and there's honestly boo her name
being announced because it was a girl
well I mean she would do great and let
me be like okay yeah so do that all
right
I know not no it's your job to train
them to it is part of your job tree but
I actually you know one of the biggest
comments when I when I do my sin I talk
about politics a lot of Russia and
Russian politics and all that one of the
most rewarding comments for me that I
sometimes get is Oh someone's actually
talking about real stuff and it's not
every gig necessarily that that might
happen but when I get that I'm like okay
there's actually an audience out there
that's interested in more than who jokes
you know what I mean yes there are there
is and and again I might suggest that
you spend more time amongst the
alternative comedy scene you will see
comics working on that subject manner I
started in the black comedy scene in San
Cisco because I couldn't find in clubs
that have booked me and a black
audiences were fantastic to me they were
very all-embracing I did I didn't have
to be closeted around them they didn't
care about anything they didn't care
about my politics either or where I came
from and they it was like the the comics
I worked with were incredibly supportive
because at the time you know being queer
was such such a difficulty in 1988-89 90
so many all my friends were dead you
bring that up in front of Akane so they
give you talking about middle class
white people serious ago had no idea
what I was discussing and he was right
down the road from them so you you can
probably find I found a group that you
need a bit of support to when you first
start out I know that it's hard for new
comics because they want to get work and
they don't want to put you know it's not
really even the audience are so worried
about but the promoters and producers
and the club owners there's only so much
you can push them before you get banned
I know that because I I've had an
experience with some of them recently
these young people I think [ __ ]
brilliant were you planning a no I
I got been banned from to Klaus and one
club called my employer and stuff and
alerted them
about how my politics were my comedy
show essential I'm like so I know you
have to be you know you're powerless
when you're new although you have your
youth on your side you should utilize
that as much as possible so just find is
supportive you know or create it you
know create a club I thought that's what
is art did yeah you know you starting a
club so awesome well this five minutes
of free advice for me yeah but you can
imagine would have been like for some
like Eddie when he started what would an
anomaly right where would you perform
some of course Easter or Julian yeah
yeah you know Clary how to have a
bodyguard in [ __ ] cuz you know it was
tough hmm alright if you're still with
us
mm-hm subscribe to us and take a little
bell next to subscribe and then you
actually get a notification of my new
videos follow us on Twitter at trigger
pod Scott before we let you go you you
you hate people clapping you on Twitter
but if people want to follow you on
twitter yes it's my name Scott Cooper oh
yeah yeah and there's anything else we
need to plug this is probably will go
out after Aaron Burr uh no no I'll be in
California October we have fury
everywhere all right all those states
our own website alright perfect go to
Scotts website check them out he's a
fantastic comedian but talk about it
touchy bunch of [ __ ] see you there very
very funny guy
I want to a dad constant technician
Francis on Twitter at foiling human
absolutely appropriate and there we all
will see you next week
thank you
[Music]